[Music]
so
when i'm thinking through a project like
this i
kind of want to map out in my head or on
a piece of paper sort of what i want to
do and where i want things to go um so
in this case right we have this
need um to adopt a persona every day
with a secret code name
um
and so
we can use pins for that um kind of as a
backbone for this because
we might end up deciding that we want um
for one a shiny app right that we can
log into and we can see what our what
our code name is for the day we might
want a daily email that tells us what
our code name is delivered to our box or
we could even go so far as you know
let's let's make a um
a slack bot right that runs and it sends
me a slack message and tells me what my
name is these kinds of things right so
so we might have need for
this information of what our daily
generated code name is going to be
delivered in multiple ways
and so that's why i think using a pen
for this information of what's my real
name and what's my code name going to be
so we're going to start off right and
we're going to have this
pen we're going to have our
our username right you have to forget my
handwriting
and our code name
right and so this is just going to be
data right what's this going to be so
we're going to take this you'll love
this we're going to stick this thing on
a pen right
use this here
how are we going to get this information
right we want this to be updated on a
daily basis
and so one of the best ways that we can
do this
let's make a little script right
and
this is going to be
generate that's what that says generate
pen
this is going to be a
our markdown document
and we're just going to schedule this
little puppy right
we'll publish this onto connect we'll
schedule it so every single day my our
markdown document is going to take my
list of users
take a list of generated code names
smoosh them together and stick it into a
pen
so
we'll do that
stick this up here
and then from this right we have other
things that we can do we can make a
shiny app right
you
are
right here's your shiny up
right and you can do um
shiny right stick this here
um you could do other things right you
could have a slack bot
you could have an email
right and that email you know we would
generate that
we'd generate that with an our markdown
document
and blastula for example right um have
connect send that on our behalf via our
markdown um the slackbot as well we can
generate that with a script cook that up
in our markdown so all of these things
[Music]
are using our pen
so these are all the little elements
that we're going to put into place
um
you might go back to this beginning and
say well okay how we're going to get our
usernames
um and where are we going to pull this
from just so happens i have another pin
just sitting around that does have um
all of the usernames
for um folks that are on our connect
server
so i've already got this as a pen so
what a fun project we're actually gonna
start with
data that's pinned
bring it into an armor arm rack down
create another pen and then use it for
downstream assets
sound fun
all right so let's get cooking we'll
start with
this our markdown document that's going
to be our pin generator right so we need
to pull in our usernames
so
um
generate
um
pen
only doing one pen
all right
clean all of this stuff up
and so what do we want to do first we
need to
get some libraries in
we're gonna need pens
we're gonna need
deep wire
um my favorite i need to spell it
correctly
um my favorite little package for um
generating code names
one one called ids
okay so this should be all that we need
first we're going to go grab the user
data information that we have
so we're going to use pens definer board
um board
rsc connect
and run that
so yep we've got our board defined
and let's get
our users
send board and
read
into my board and it is
what is it user
users user i think it's user let's try
it
hey it seemed to work okay awesome we've
got user information 166 users cool
all right so we can take this
um we don't need any of this other stuff
what i want to do is just get user name
and assign a code name
and my ultimate goal for this shiny app
um
is i want the user
to um
log in
pull up the shiny app and i want the
shiny app to know who that user is
and then tell them their code name
um so we're going to use um for that app
just
kind of charting the course here
we're going to use this ability to do
session dollar sign user um on the app
so that we can distinguish who is who
and now let's make up some code names um
so let's make a table here
code names
let's take users and
we just want
username and we want to mutate
let's stick a code name
equals uh let's see i gotta go by memory
let's play around a minute with this ids
um
function id's adjective animal okay
positive animal
n equals one let's do let's just for
kicks let's spit out five
one adjective let's make case and let's
just see if we get
ah
cool
oh no i don't like some of those but all
right run this a couple of times and
we've got some good stuff
okay so this is what we want to do we
want to use adjective animal code name
equals adjective animal
and let's see
some of these can be a little bit um
wild so let's put i remember from other
playing with this package it gets a
little
um
some of the names get to be a little bit
excessive if you don't put a maximum
length on it so let's see what we get
that's not good everybody's a frugal
pickle um we need to do
oh let's do this
oops
in
equal no in row
and ah
and equals number of rows and users is
that going to get me
so i have unique names
yes
that's awesome
concave flamingo
all right now
we are cooking every time we run this
it's going to cook up new names so i
want to make it unique for every day um
so let's
let's set the seed
um and
does this work as numeric
stay
all right set the seed
code names
do we get the same
ah i didn't set the c twice
lazy mute
perfect
okay
we have stable code names
and now all we need to do
i'm not documenting my code very well
create
code name this is obvious table
and now we need to append it
so we're gonna take our board
type that into pen right
and we're going to put
code names to it
[Music]
i'm going to publish this as well
so we can put it on a schedule
so let's publish this little
[Music]
put that there
we're going to publish this
[Music]
there we go we are deployed
all right so we've got our pen generator
we're writing depends now
let's
schedule this otherwise we're going to
end up with the same code name every day
so let's run this
and yeah we should probably run this
just a little after midnight every day
that sounds good
so now this is going to run it's going
to run on a daily basis
so here's our graphic of where we are um
it's going to run and every day
update this pin for us
[Music]
so said we wanted to make this shiny app
right that's going to
code
name
it's going to tell us every day what our
code name is
i am not the world's most elegant
shiny
uh developer but i will get by nice
there we go
yes
i love a good clean slate okay
so for our shine yet we're gonna need
shiny
uh let's see how we're gonna need
anything else we're of course gonna need
pens
again can't spell
pens
and then all right so what do we want
this to do
um
first we're going to want to
bring in
um
bring
in our
code name
table so we're going to do that
board this is going to look familiar
right board equals
um
rs connect
and
code names equals
and read
board
and then what we call it
what do we call it do we call it code
names
i think so
all right cross your fingers
[Music]
we're cooking code names
there we are you're lazy newt okay
so
where were we um we need to
bring it all in and have a nice little
greeting so um let's do
like on our main
panel
let's give um
[Music]
i'll just put
output
and
this will just be our
greeting
all right
and then what is our greeting it is
going to be
something along the lines of
what do we do text right
render
text
and then let's do
like uh
hello
secret agent
and then we need to put in the
[Music]
username however we determine it to be
all right
um we need to figure out what our
username is going to be
um so how do we know the username so two
things right we're gonna know the
username based on who is logged in um
so the username is going to be
all right so um
username
equals session dollar sign user
um
however i want to be able to test
this
locally um
so i'm gonna do a little
environment swaparoo
so we're gonna do
all right so we're going to set our
default all right and we're just
developing locally
we're going to say that our default is
me
um and then when you're using um
when you're using
the session dollar sign user and you
want that can be identified with the
environment variable for
our config so let's do
get environment variable
our config
so if the active
configuration is rs connect
all right is this making sense
our config active is rs connect username
is session dollar sign user otherwise
it's linked all right
output reading hello
all right and now we also need to figure
out what our code name is going to be so
we say hello to ourselves and then we
say
um
you shall be known
as
there we go
and then we will put in
text output
um
third name
okay
now i can define what the code name is
going to be
so codename
equals
under
text
use your
code name let's call it
we have to define what that is so let's
stick that up here
use your
name
so we've got the pen we've got the pin
with our username and our code name so
we're just going to take our code
names
table
filter it
user name equals
and then we'll just pull
so for kicks all right so if we say
usually this
we've got our code names what do we end
up with
code
oh a cod name
oh
those cods okay
so it is
god
makes it even more
secretive
let's see is that going to bite us
anywhere else there's
feisty cod i think we should be in good
shape okay so let's test this out see if
this runs locally
fabulous
let's publish this puppy
let's go code
names generator
let's call it
secret
generator
[Music]
oh can't find po
for every
deep flyer to the rescue
all right try that again
exposable tuna
so from here i guess we could like leave
it an exercise to the reader
to build out more assets to round out
our secret agent personas
[Music]